crazy si tu dois protéger tes poule c et
minéral c'est très bien leur nom
mais je peux vous dire que dans le
mâconnais
quelles que soient les enjeux et ne
lâche rien bonjour bonjour à tous allez
j'ose en bacs cette semaine direction la
bourgogne du sud
on va remonter le temps ensemble ça se
passera à la grottes d'azé pouvez même
les sources sont passés par là et puis
nous continuerons notre ascension ce
coup-ci à la roche de solutré
mais je vous promets qu'arriver en eau
eh bien on aura un paysage somptueux
alors ce que vous propose aujourd'hui
c'est une fabuleuse ascension sur le
chemin de la petite et de la grande
histoire entre le clunysois et le
mâconnais est revenu on y va c'est ici
c'est maintenant et puis c'est la la
[Musique]
première étape de l'escapade la roche de
solutré
le site est emblématique de l'as au noir
laroche surplombe la commune de solutré
pouilly a tout juste 8 km à l'ouest de
macron j'avais pris rendez vous avec
hervé guide et mérite de ce grand site
il le parcours depuis sa plus tendre
enfance et je crois bien qu'il en
connaît tous les recoins
bonjour bonjour connais bien sûr mais
dans la baie franchement un petit peu à
tout le temps eu des arts de ce matin
toi qui connais bien le lyonnais est ce
que tu penses que ça va s'ouvrir et je
pense que ça sourire quand on a une pour
autant la hausse est bon le problème
alors qu'est ce que tu me réserve eh
bien on va faire l'ascension de la roche
de solutré avec lui mine à 13 mètres des
petites précisément d'accord c'est pas
trés trés ou non c'est pas très haut il
ya en se promenant il faut une heure et
demi pour monter avait presque le
solaire voilà vingt minutes pour un
grand sportif
et alors quoi moi je suis pas loin il ya
énormément de chemin pour monter sur la
roche mais maintenant il ya un chemin
qui est ouvert au public est réservée au
public parce que les autres accès sont
dangereux on les toitures et les axes
est dangereux non non non ils sont
vraiment dans une jupe lui loge spectre
et aventureuse et tout le monde faisait
sur tous les tons on est enfant oui nous
apprenons la voie royale alors de tout
temps la roche de solutré a inspirés les
hommes illustres inconnus ou sommes plus
fameux
son ascension est devenue célèbre
lorsque françois mitterrand après la
guerre a honoré un serment fait avec une
poignée de résistants gravir la roche
chaque année et aujourd'hui
et bien c'est un bon tu sais la
rencontre n'ont jamais en 50 ans il est
venu faire l'ascension sauf une fois en
tout comme les journalistes l'attendant
au régime et nous la croisée des chemins
où est ce qu'on va ça c'est le chemin
officiel comprendre le touriste lambda
et nour emprunté celui ci travaille
ancien chemin qui est fermé mais qu'on
va prouverez exceptionnellement
aujourd'hui j'ai de la chance
carnet ata combien de monter pas depuis
que ce travail chez pol bat 520 700 ça
va très vite
moi je la vois tous les jours tous les
jours depuis chez moi j'ai toujours je
trouve quelque chose de différent
et quand on est dessus ben c'est pas
c'est ma région quoi commencer
aujourd'hui
là on a vraiment toutes les unités du
paysage du mâconnais magnifique entre
laisse les forêts la vigne ouais le
village les roches les pelouses
calcaires et tout au fond là-bas le
bocage le paysage autour de la hausse
est spectaculaire par sa diversité il
nous envoûte
donc nous avons ainsi un paysage qui
était entièrement façonnés par l'homme
on a par exemple ici le bocage avec la
prairie et les est au fond la forêt qui
a poussé sur des terrains délaissés par
la vigne après on a bien sûr la vigne
qui entoure le village laroche dominer
tout ça non c'est pas l'homme mais ce
qui l'a façonné c'est la partie
supérieure les pelouses calcaires où il
faisait pâture et ses chefs des vaches
mais tout ça c'est si on ne fait pas
pâturer cette partie ça devient une
forêt très rapidement
c'est la main de l'homme qui a façonné
les paysages doucement siècle après
siècle comme une grande leçon de
l'histoire ou quand aménager
l'environnement rimait avec diversité et
respect de la nature et on n'a pas volé
un nom ce moment de répondre quelquefois
la part des jours où on voit le mont
blanc mais comme s'il était un
d'autre côté quoi alors qu'il est à 100
sous 80 km la roche est aussi le théâtre
d'une légende et rouge
les chasseurs du paléolithique guidée
des troupeaux de chevaux sauvages
jusqu'au sommet pour ensuite les
précipiter dans le vide
mais la réalité est bien plus simple
c'est une roche en fait qui a été habité
d l'ère paléolithique politique
supérieure alors elles n'étaient pas
habitées il devait s'en servir comme
point d'observation comme tous les gens
qui comme nous et d'ailleurs pour
observer visage mais c'est à personne
une chose c'est que les chevaux qui
pâturent est dans la plaine de la saône
remonté par à peu près toujours le même
chemin il devait passer au pied de la
roche et là il avait organisé une espèce
de 2 comment dire de souricière où il
capture il faut il tuer les choux et
après ils les ce qu'on appelle le cros
du charnier au pied de la roche est là
il est dépassé et c'est pour ça qu'on a
trouvé l'équivalent de plus de 100000
carcasse de chevaux et de rennes qui ont
été déposées dans ce petit hectare ici
par moments il ya plus d'un mètre
cinquante de p 102 merci beaucoup énervé
j'ai vraiment envie de remercier parce
qu'on a passé une un bon moment où est
un bon moment
[Musique]
à quelques kilomètres au nord de la
roche dans le petit village de soligny
se trouve un gîte ce pas comme les
autres un lieu unique est étonnant une
des plus grandes collections de jeux de
société du pays dans un gîte
ouvert à tous nous sommes à l'escala jeu
[Musique]
et bonjour bonjour et bienvenue à
l'escala jeu merci beaucoup
écoutez vous allez voir vous même c'est
un gîte un peu spéciale avec 8000 jeux à
disposition
voilà donc les ce cas là je sais ça oui
c'est beau c'est grand
une ludothèque sert une bibliothèque de
jeux mais tout ça à dos et un gîte où on
peut venir dormir jusqu'à 15 ans vient
particulièrement profond et il ya des
gens qui viennent pour découvrir la
région et découvre les jeux et des gens
qui viennent pour jouer il découvre la
région
donc tu intime de jeu préféré toi ben
moi mon type de jeu préféré c'est plutôt
les jeux familiaux mais il ya toutes
sortes de jeux il ya des petits jeux qui
dure trois minutes des jeux qui dure
quatre heures
mais toi tu veux ici un jeu oui bien sûr
belge en l1 qui s'explique en 5 secondes
allons-y les amis permettez moi de vous
présenter une nouvelle joueuse gaël
alors choisi si tu dois protéger tes
poule d'accord quoi on a bien sûr ça
c'est sa lassitude à plus ou moins fort
paris va viser quelqu'un c'est bien
c'est très bien
il a raison quand même donc sa familiale
par excellence quoi ça c'est entre deux
parties de jeux plus sérieux on se
détend avec ce genre de choses
oui davantage c'est quand on perd c'est
pas très grave y'a pas trop dangereux
non il est pas trop d'enjeu et puis on
n'a pas l'impression non plus d'avoir
abaissé intellectuellement ben non ça
remet les gants face à maintenant c'est
quand même du hasard c'est jean claude
qui a gagné et bien c'est que tu te fais
des amis tu veux il ya des jeux d'un
autre type aussi quand même il existe
des jeux d'autres types qui sont
réfléchies des jeux qui sont là pour
rigoler des jeux qui sont là pour
réfléchir des jeux sur las pour eux pour
jouer ensemble
mais ces jeux sont surtout là pour être
partagé pas question de les laisser sous
cloche comme dans un musée
ici on peut toucher à tout et même hors
hard as love money et bézy dont tu
devrais fléché chez toi ah oui voit
peut-être que je donne des nombreux mais
j'en ai pas mis pour l'instant tu m'as
préparer déjà oui alors c'est quelques
jeux que j'aime bien mon trip sont des
jeux assez anciens des années 60-70
festival de cannes un jeu sur les
vedettes du festival de cannes avec deux
dents que des photos des studios
d'harcourt où il a dû avoir du succès à
une époque où un bel objet c'est la très
bel objet du mail
non ils vont pas bien sûr les jeux ont
une durée de vie courte
c'est dommage au poly et magnifique jeu
qui a été fait par les travailleurs de
l'ip pendant là pendant les événements
de la grève de l'ip et on trouve même
des témoignages ou le directeur qui
étaient séquestrés a participé à la
création du jeu avec les avec les ouvre
ainsi une famille voilà tu penses toi
faire partie de la communauté de gamers
entre guillemets c'est un des rares
loisirs de l'esprit où on est acteur
parce que la plupart des loisirs de
l'esprit on est spectateur on va au
cinéma ou au théâtre on va avoir un
concert on va voir un spectacle de danse
mais on est rarement acteurs au jeu on
est acteur tout le temps alors il met
jouer au jeu c'est une chose mais en
avoir autant que ça c'est un peu fou en
fait moi la collection a grossi grossi
bon c'est ça quand on tombe dans une
folie on est dedans quoi ça tellement
grossi qu'à un moment on s'est dit
qu'est ce qu'on fait et ça s'entassaient
dans une petite maison aux alentours de
lyon
et puis on a dit bon on va acheter une
maison plus grande tous les jouets pour
les enfants on rajoute des pièces et
tout vendre lancé pour les jeux du coup
on a choisi fallait trouver une maison
on puisse se loger m tous les jeux et
avoir de la place pour loger des gens
qui allaient venir vivre au mieux de ce
jeu c'était tentant de rester encore un
peu à l'escaladieu mais j'avais réservé
mon gîte ailleurs à deux encablures de
pluie à la corbeille ici nous sommes
chez édith et bruno leur faire mais ce
que l'on appelle un accueil paysan
pas de chichi en accueille en pleine
exploitation au milieu des animaux
il élève des vaches à viande et quelques
moutons
le tout en agriculture biologique ils
ont imaginé une façon très originale de
recevoir leurs hôtes de passage ici dans
le clunisois
[Musique]
ma chambre était un peu particulière
comme vous pouvez le voir
[Musique]
bonjour ça eddine là d'accord veut
m'accueillir ces supers goujats vous
avez réservé notre but oui la bulle de
campagne voilà voilà qui est vraiment de
campagne parce qu'ici on est sur une
ferme une ferme en activité et donc la
bulle
elle est vraiment caché au coeur de la
ferme à côté des animaux tout à fait je
me suis on passe pas aller s qu'ici ça a
toujours été un lieu d'accueil anneaux
enfin d'accueil parce que d'antan c'est
vrai que dans les fermes y avait
beaucoup de convivialité beaucoup
d'entre elles dont il ya toujours eu du
monde mais le lieu d'accueil
la ferme a toujours existé et le lieu
d'accueil c'est depuis une quinzaine
d'années c'était mon idée
j'ai voulu créer des chambres d'hôtes à
la ferme donc voilà et puis cette année
on a rajouté des hébergements insolites
combien vous avez 2 vaches on à 65
merveille une grande partie de
charolaises et puis aussi des vaches
salers en fait accueillir les gens ici
comme moi aujourd'hui c'est un peu une
façon pour vous pour bruno et toi de
faire connaître votre travail
oui oui tout à fait les gens sont
parfois surpris en règle générale
agréablement surpris parce que les gens
ont un peu dans la tête l'agriculture
industrielle et il découvre que
effectivement c'est pas tout à fait ça
vous êtes paysans on est des vrais pb et
on revendique ce terme
la bulle est caché tout au fond de la
ferme
elle est transparente à l'abri des
regards indiscrets et face à la forêt
c'est dormir à la belle étoile mais avec
tout le confort c'est une bulle dans
cette parenthèse campagne assez assez
grand c'est surprenant mais tu vas voir
tu veux venir voir l'intérieur quand
même avoir à l'intérieur
alors il ya des petites précautions à
prendre dans la bulle il ya des
fermetures pour entrer il ya un sas donc
on n'ouvre jamais les deux fermetures en
même temps sinon la bulle
savoir
vous regardez la tombe où on a
l'impression d'être dehors sauf qu'on
est protégé on est produit riche et on
peut être les chauffages ya pas de
petites bêtes qui rend normalement on
peut être nu la personne ne nous voit
mais voilà les vaches mais répète pas
elle pas de sa tombe est alors la nuit
talent et ses toiles
merci a dit génial et c'est pas le
paradis ça sert semble un pour moi et si
j'ai la chance devant un chevreuil
alors là je mens qui gagne allez bonne
nuit
[Musique]
le haut clunysois re est une terre de
vos cages et d'élevage ici à montilliers
francis et ses ânes ont pris leurs
quartiers au milieu des prés et si les
ânes ne servent plus beaucoup aux
travaux des champs
ils ont aujourd'hui une toute autre
fonction
[Musique]
on attend
bonjour gaël 11 ans francis c'est gentil
comme tout de m'accueillir
c'est un grand plaisir à ces gentils
alors c'est ici et j'imagine je voyais
donc les ânes là j'imagine que ce sont
des ânes exactement
voilà quatre ânes alors leur nom donc
comme gaspard pompon ali et vidocq et
vidéo qui est aujourd'hui étant le plus
jeune un vidocq
tiens ça te dit une petite pomme laloui
ça me dit tu vas chercher alors tu vient
la chercher seulement si tu veux aller
chercher sa chercher ou par ekoko qui
composent et compte trois salut toi non
ce n'est pas encore un nom francis andré
était guide et éducateurs dans le jura
un jour il a rencontré cézanne pompons
et gaspard et ce fut une révélation il
allait alors devenir a nié s'installer
dans le free ni loi et utiliser cet
animal dans son activité quotidienne
depuis pour lui tout a changé
ça va à peu près 20 ans je travaille
déjà voilà et donc avec cela donc trois
particuliers popo gaspard et ali ça va
faire très de 15 ans qu'en fin de compte
que le temps passe et je pense que là il
est à taille humaine jouer à un niveau
de l'enfant quand il est en france on
petit vous pas peur de la honte que
c'est moins haut que les petits gabarits
ben oui c'est ça un bon compagnon de
travail mais aussi les années bien être
entouré donc plus il ya d'ambiance
autour d'eux plus ils se sentent bien
quoi
l'aneth originaires de régions
désertiques la fuite lui est impossible
il a appris à observer et à trouver des
solutions par ses propres moyens
c'est un animal très prudent et ce
tempérament est à l'origine de sa
réputation
si les juges d'un passage dangereux rien
ne pourra le forcer à avancer il a
besoin de contacts et de confiance le
pompon
[Musique]
non
tahar de freiner
[Musique]
et c'est pour t'accompagner un peu la
navette formation le pas de la norway
tusa telle centrale
en fait un peu droite là et là la droite
[Musique]
l'âne a longtemps été un allié pour le
travail mais aujourd'hui ceux de francis
sont surtout un vecteur d'éducation de
partage de découverte
quelles qualités il à 7,7 à nos malades
ou quoi l'année du raffut rang et puis
là ne juge pas voilà ne triche pas il ne
juge pas donc il prend les gens comme
ils sont là n'a besoin d'être éduqués
mag attend quoi et puis après après on
peut lui demander un tas de choses qu
enfin lorsqu'on les voit au contact
d'enfants
on voit bien qu'il se passe quelque
chose les prétendants dans l'inconscient
collectif
mais moi j'ai envie de continuer à
présenter la halle comme un animal
compagnon de l'homme
pour ceux qui veulent explorer les
blocages du pli niçois francis propose
des randonnées toute l'année n'hésitez
donc pas à les voir gaspard répondant à
montilliers pas question de parcours et
le clunysois s'en aller jeter un oeil
aux grottes d'azé tout est là cachées
sous cette colline un site préhistorique
qui couvrent une période allant jusqu'à
250 mille ans avant notre ère
j'avais rendez vous avec didier
il a participé aux exploration
souterraine dans les années soixante dix
nous voilà en grande aînée a bien trouvé
ses biens voilà enfin andy goode
d'azeroth d'azé oui mais il ya quand
même une petite nuance c'est qu'il ya il
y a deux grottes en fait il ya la balme
de rochebelle et la balme de reese rôle
la balme voulant dire une grotte surtout
dans le sud c'est utilisé sur toulon sud
mais même même dans notre région une
balle mais c'est une grotte aussi c'est
par là bas c'est par là bas je vais te
montrer d'ailleurs le plan comme ça on
situera un petit peu macériens sa bonne
idée bonne idée parce que j'irais bien
la résurgence mais je sais pas vraiment
si si c'est faisable même expliqué les
deux grottes sont aujourd'hui
accessibles au public l'une suit le
cours de la rivière souterraine
l'autre a été habité par l'homme mais
surtout par de grands fauves du
quaternaire des ours et des lion des
cavernes
azé sa grotte vieille de mille siècles
qui attire bon an mal an quelque 15000
visiteurs grâce au travail gigantesque
de spéléo et archéologue amateur
didier est un témoin important de cette
époque on vient de découvrir un
cimetière d'ours âgé de cinquante mille
ans au moins tout était à dégager dans
ses galeries complètement noyés et
douché par l'argile voilà que cet ici on
arrive voilà la grotte préhistorique
évident qu'elle est bien protégé allait
dire qu'un coffre-fort
ah oui les dimensions de la galerie
d'entre elles sont assez
impressionnantes pour la bourgogne c'est
une grande entrée
sept mètres de hauteur et à peu près
autant en largeur tu vois là c'est
vraiment les dimensions qui sortent de
l'ordinaire cette grotte là on peut
s'imaginer une vie qui remonte à quand
j'ai me suis laissé dire 250 mille ans
est ce que c'est vrai cette grotte elle
a servi de refuge à différentes époques
quand les époques était troublé quand il
y avait des guerres quand il y avait des
périodes avec des ddd maladie tu vois
des styles la peste ou d'autres
les gens veulent se réfugier bien dans
les entrées de grottes par contre
l'homme préhistorique quand on n'a pas
trouvé beaucoup de traces on sait qu' il
y a de l'outillage préhistorique qui
date d'environ 250 mille ans mais c'est
tout ce qu'on a trouvé pour l'instant
ici il faut se dire qu'à l'origine il y
avait quand même beaucoup plus de terres
et au fur et à mesure qu'on va rentrer
tu vas voir qu'il ya eu énormément d'un
de sédiments qui ont été enlevés et dans
ces sédiments
à certains endroits on a trouvé les ours
et ben nous on essaie quand même on va
essayer d'avancer parce que ses
débouchés vers seulement ça va
impressionnant
tiens voilà exactement ce que je voulais
te montrer tu vois ici c'est un coin que
j'adore c'est vraiment superbe
c'est des micros gour l'oissu est sûre
le calcaire et dépose à chaque fois une
toute petite pellicule et ça fait des
centaines de petits bourgs comme ça on a
l'impression que c'est vu ça ressemble à
du ciel
essayez de la calcite c'est la
décomposition du calcaire par laurent du
acide qui fait 7 quel site bien blanche
en fait ça bouge tout le temps ça ça a
été formé temps à ça c'est très récent
ça a été formé après la désobstruction
de la grotte en 1963 donc depuis 1963 tu
vois donc ça va très vite
c'est ce qui prouve que la grotte est
encore vivante et encore l'eau qui
apporte de la vie donc c'est encore un
beau terrain de jeu pour toi c'est
encore un bon terrain de jeu pour les
spéléos
[Musique]
alors là on arrive dans le saint des
saints des ours
là où il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
vestiges d'ours
celui ci par exemple qui est entier
alors tu vois un petit peu là la
dimension du squelette ça donne un petit
peu une idée de la taille qui avait ses
petites bêtes 1 c'est impressionnant et
ça bouge pas ça quand l'eau vient
univers l'hiver il ya un petit peu d'eau
mais non ça recoupe de quel site on voit
ces blancs mais ça reste en place non
non ça bouge pas parce que l'eau est
stagnante elle n'est pas allée pas
courant donc ça bouge pas qu'est ce
qu'il est il ya trois cent mille ans nos
sources ils venaient ici et il devait
passer l'hiver blotti la mère et son
petit blottis l'un contre l'autre
et de toute façon pendant tout l'hiver
elle se nourrissait pas donc elle vivait
sur ses réserves de graisse est ce qu'il
existe encore cet ours alors l'ours tels
qu'ils étaient là non il a il a des
descendants mais qui sont différents
[Musique]
ça c'était dur suspect d uc ursus des
mines gerry est aujourd'hui c'est l'ours
brun c'est le grizzly tu vois c'est des
nouvelles espèces qui sont apparues
après ça c'est dans la lignée c'est leur
ancêtre ça et alors à côté il ya des tas
d'ossements
c'est impressionnant c'est un chant
documents en bien de tous là on a
retrouvé une quantité d'eau assez
important donc ça devait être vraiment
un endroit où les ours sont venus et il
faut il faut imaginer que ça se passe
pendant deux cents mille ans donc même à
raison de un ou deux jours se parent sur
deux cent mille ans ça fait beaucoup
d'énergie beaucoup c'est clair on est là
c'était rempli dos pratiquement jusqu'au
plafond la tuer ça laisse sans voix
est ce que tu penses que ce qui t'attend
derrière là là vous êtes en train
d'avancer avec les autres spéléologues
ça va être d'une intensité aussi grande
que ces découvertes là je pense que ça
peut tout à fait possible parce que là
la galerie quand on voit les dimensions
plus loin un endroit on a une galerie
qui doit faire 8 mètres de large à 80
mètres d'ici on a retrouvé un petit
ourson je pense qu'on peut en trouver
peut-être encore plus loin c'est une des
signatures dazeas et c'est connu surtout
heureuse de ces sources et c'est quelque
chose qui est fabuleux quoi j'aurais
bien aimé enfin les voir ces sources à
l'époque tu as parce que je me dis que
ça dd sacrée bête et puis l'ambiance
qu'il devait y avoir dans ses galeries
cantine grogner quand face à ça devait
être assez fabuleux quand même sans
éclairage dans le noir savent quelque
chose
bon ben si avec ça vous ne savez pas où
passer vos futurs week-end franchement
moi là allez je vous embrasse d'ici la
semaine prochaine vous prenez grand soin
de vous en reste en lien sur les réseaux
sociaux par exemple ma page facebook
instagram aussi je vous embrasse très
fort et je vous dis à la semaine
prochaine merci encore de votre fidélité
bye bye